let's stay in texas deshaun watson we
had seen nor heard not a thing from him
since
he's the one and and so much has
happened over the last two months it's
easy to forget
he's the one who let us all know that
there was some sort of lawsuit that had
been threatened against him or was going
to be filed hadn't been filed yet
whatever it was that's when i first
became aware of it that's when many
first became aware of it don't follow
tony busby on social media frankly and
tony this may come as a surprise to you
i hadn't even heard of you before this
all came up now big deal in houston but
i'm not plugged into the houston legal
community or people who ran for mayor in
houston i didn't know who tony busby was
but i knew who desean watson was and
he's the one who told me what was going
down we hadn't heard from him since then
and we didn't hear from him yesterday
but we saw desean watson putting in the
work
to get ready to play football at a time
when we're not quite sure when if how
where he's gonna play he's getting ready
to play he's out there on the field he's
moving around he's doing drills chris
and and again this is the first we've
seen of him this is proof of life from
deshaun watson for the first time in two
months yeah it is it's you know we we're
getting a a look at him hey just like
hey here's this guy let's not forget
about him but i think more than anything
it's just showing you know
it's it's a way for desean watson and
his camp to get it out they're like hey
i i know all this stuff's going on in
the world but this guy's still focused
on football you know uh you know hello
all 31 other teams that might want to
trade for deshaun watson you know when
this all gets settled and everything
like that so i think that's the message
you're trying to send here right mike
the guy's still worried about his
business he's still worried about it
being a great quarterback and he's doing
that work even though he's not with the
texans and has all this outside noise
going on right now in his life
you know it's funny though given recent
developments
i know the first thing i thought of when
i saw him out there doing his drills on
the field juwan james first thing i
thought of yeah
yeah right because here here's how it
would go down and no one can claim that
they don't know now yeah desean watson
working out on his own away from the
texans he could have shown up and
participated in whatever the texans have
going on now i don't know maybe the
league would be uncomfortable maybe the
texans would be uncomfortable but he has
every right to show up and if you get
injured while you're there you're
covered and and this would be look no
one ever wants to see a guy get injured
but the texans for now are staring at
the possibility of cases don't get
resolved
watson shows up for training camp and i
strongly believe he's showing up for
training camp under these circumstances
because you either don't show up and get
fined and don't get paid or you show up
get put on paid leave and get paid
texans are looking at paying them over
10 million dollars this year to not play
if these cases aren't resolved and he's
untradeable hey if if he would suffer an
injury while working out on his own and
be in the juan james category
that's the best case scenario for the
texans short of a trade sure being able
to get value for moving on because your
other alternative is paying him 10
million dollars and he doesn't play if
he's not going to play why pay him yeah
no i mean i i hear what you're saying
but that is the thing right like yeah
okay injury
texans might be off the hook paying them
that way but you also might be off the
hook from being able to trade them at
that moment too so that's where that's
affected by that so
i i'm with you mike i would think at
some point if nothing's done deshawn
watson does
you know go to training camp for all the
reasons you stated but either way i
think it's just again
there's been a few positive things from
his side of the camp here the last few
weeks you know i do think you know his
rep representative rusty harden has done
a good job of fighting back in the
public a little bit to sway public
opinion back to you know even or maybe
even favor desean watson here in some
moments or whatever like that to where
we question everything again so that's a
positive and i like you said we haven't
seen him so it's just great to see the
guy and see him working out and going
okay yeah there he is all right you know
it's just a a check-in period and uh of
course he is one of the five six best
quarterbacks of football one of the best
players in the league and uh as soon as
this gets settled you and i both know
there's going to be teams calling the
houston texans rusty hardin has made it
clear that he's not going to let desean
watson speak on these matters publicly
and we're all familiar with the miranda
warnings anything you say canon will be
used against you that happens when
someone's placed under arrest but the
reality is if you're the defendant in
any proceeding even in a civil
proceeding anything you say can and will
be used against you potentially so you
don't let the guy talk now i don't know
and it's possible rusty harden
didn't have the conversation about
posting instagram videos it's possible
desean just did it under that notion of
it's better
to seek forgiveness than permission
but it's it's not like it jeopardizes
him right i don't think nothing about
that video that you would look at and
say oh god desean why did you do that
it's a video of him working out plain
and simple it doesn't affect his his
legal situation in any way but you don't
want the client to be making that
decision on his or her own and for all
we know rusty harden saw it and said i'm
fine with it but there's also a chance
deshawn just decided this doesn't have
anything to do with the cases i'm just
going to go ahead and put it on my
instagram page yeah no harm no foul but
i would hope that
anything he does right now he runs by
rusty hardin right i mean i i would hope
and then i would hope hardin would go
yeah okay hey you're working out yeah
let's show everybody you are in shape
you're still thinking about football
that is what you're here for this is why
you know again we're in the circumstance
and it is news it's because he's a
superstar football player so he can't
forget about that aspect of his life and
and not train and be ready and all that
other thing i just thought you know that
i just noticed there too because i i
feel like i've heard these rumors but
like they were filming him
but there was another guy there with a
camera like what's they i i feel like i
heard rumors that there was a
documentary going on with desean watson
maybe but that's a professional camera
like i noticed those from here at nbc
and stuff that's where i just wonder
does he have somebody record him like
that to look at technique or is there
something being done about his life
right now
yeah i don't know you've got a camera
and a camera right like my dream from
the other night it's inception it's a
camera of a guy with a camera of a guy
with a camera of a guy with a camera so
that's a good point and who knows who
knows but it does that does look like a
professional camera with some sort of a
steadying
mechanism uh
uh yeah i i don't know but that's uh
that's something we'll just have to wait
and find out and and as it relates to
the advice that rusty hardin would give
to sean watson just so folks understand
this you don't want him talking to
anyone anytime anyplace publicly or
privately the message is never talk to
anyone about anything remotely related
to the situation you feel compelled to
talk to anybody about it call me call
one of the people that work for me the
attorney-client privilege applies to
them anybody else you talk to you never
know you never know if you can trust
them you never know if that's going to
show up somewhere you never know who's
going to get questioned by the other
lawyer
and forced to admit to whatever was said
whether it's a family member a close
friend whatever you don't want to put
anybody in a tough spot never say
anything and i i i haven't heard
anything to suggest that desean watson
has and he's never struck me as the kind
of guy who feels compelled to say a lot
of things publicly or privately about
sensitive matters so this all continues
to go forward you know after last week's
dust up between the lawyers it's gotten
quiet again no statements no instagram
posts from tony busby no press releases
they had their moment last week where
they disagreed over who made the first
move on settlement talks right rusty
hard made it clear that he wants
everything to be transparent tony busby
according to rusty harden wants it all
to be confidential busby never rebutted
that specific point directly
and so
we just continue to wait and i i still
believe yes chris the point i made over
the weekend right and it dawned on me
you're not at the point where you're
fighting over confidentiality of a
settlement agreement unless you have the
terms
of the settlement agreement right
already in place yeah you don't get to
that
it's pointless right to talk about
hypothetical theoretical confidentiality
when
the clients have a six-figure impasse
i think they had and still may have the
ball on the t financially it's just
these other issues they got to work out
and
from my own experience
once it gets to that point
where you know financially
it's worked out
life finds a way
they figure the other stuff out you
figure the other stuff out right because
everybody everybody kind of exhales
you know they take they take the lawyer
face off yeah you're not it's not one of
the cases you're now expending energy on
thinking about
what you're going to do who you're going
to question how you're going to question
when you practice law you carry that
stuff around all the time how am i going
to handle this case what am i going to
do in this case that one once you get to
the point where you know the numbers are
right it gets moved out of the category
of the cases you think about it's just a
matter of time before it goes away so i
think that's one big point from last
week that we haven't emphasized here
definitely i think they have a tentative
deal financially it's just a question of
how they work out these other terms is
is there any way mike let me ask you
this just like you know to to
you know expedite or you know
you know hasting this whole process a
little bit for like desean watson and
rusty hardin or is this one that they're
kind of just
you know beholden to the circumstances
and they got to hang in there and just
kind of wait for details to get figured
out
you know we always say the nfl is a
deadline driven business deadlines drive
everything when you're talking about
negotiation and the reason why deadlines
are important
if there is a move to be made if there
is any concession to be considered you
don't want to do it prematurely you want
to know when the time is right when both
sides understand the time has come to
work out a deal
so they both move and they get it done
and something you know there's different
ways they could handle the
confidentiality thing they could have
confidentiality as to the amounts that
were paid yeah right but full
transparency where the individuals
involved can cooperate with the league
cooperate with whoever can talk about
any of the details anytime they want
yeah so uh but but you don't want to
start
making your major concessions
when there's still time left for the
other side to say man that's not good
enough i want more you want it all to
come together and thread the needle at
the deadline and i think as a practical
matter the deadline is to start a
training camp yeah right so right now
now
i i see when when you're looking at the
i think the practical deadline is
probably before that if you want to have
a chance to trade him this is one where
it's hard to come up with
what what the deadline is i would think
it's like mid-july like your second
thought there like something where it's
like hey we'd we'd like to get fourth
yeah oh yeah or either way that that's a
general time period start of july
okay now we got time to call around
teams can figure out what they're doing
things like that we could figure out
maybe and get a feel for what the league
might do for desean watson all those
type of things uh i hear you i would
think that's got to be the time at least
for desean watson and his camp that they
go
come on like let's let's let's get this
going let's get some finality to this
situation
and you have to wonder whether there's
been any kind of conversation about what
would be offered
to the texans if and when
these cases go away yeah right now
there's been some scuttlebutt and i
haven't been able to confirm this yet
that teams currently are trying to
contact the texans
with an interest in trading for desean
watson even with this litigation baggage
and the texans aren't engaging and the
reason they wouldn't engage is they're
going to get a lot less if they trade
him with the baggage than if they wait
but it would be prudent i think at some
point for nick casario the gm of the
texans to to entertain conversations
with interested teams in the event that
the cases are resolved i mean they added
jeff driscoll yesterday they got four
quarterbacks now tyrod taylor jeff
driscoll ryan finley and davis mills
clearly desean watson is not in the
texans plans for 2021 i'd want to have
an alternative plan in place for the
moment these cases are resolved if
they're resolved so i know exactly where
i'm going to trade this guy i'd
especially because you don't want it to
happen
you know in a compressed time frame now
here's the other here's the other side
of it too chris that i just remembered
he's looking at the suspension
so it's not like you need to have him in
day one of training camp to get him
ready for one whoever trades for him if
there's a trade to be had this year
they're going to go into it assuming
four six eight games based upon what
happened with ben roethlisberger 11
years ago when he had two
claims against him not 22.
um you have to assume that he's going to
be shut down for at least the first four
games so it's not as critical it's not
as critical to get a trade done before
uh the start of training camp so i don't
know when you
when you
peg that deadline for getting a deal
done it's a valid point you're right
it takes away maybe the you know the
urgency there with that situation
i guess the only thing with nick casario
and that that just pops to my mind is a
little bit like of something that
already happened
you know i yeah if i'm you i guess i'd
want to get or him i'd want to get the
ball rolling too to like what you said
get a conversation going about maybe
some general framework of the of the the
trade or something you know the other
thing i would just be worried about if
i'm nick casario
is more bad stuff comes out here
and now
okay
yeah we're still gonna trade him but man
now he's he's definitely gonna get
suspended and the team we're gonna trade
him to now we have more bad tangible
evidence or whatever out there in the
world that doesn't look good on desean
watson they're going man
now yeah okay yeah we want to trade for
him but now this is out and now we gotta
bring him here and deal with all the
scrutiny of that and i i would think
that could lessen the trade value too so
i i would think you got to worry about
that aspect a little bit like what
happened to him earlier this offseason
well we're not going to talk to him any
need to talk to anybody we're not going
to take any deals anything any deals all
of a sudden everything bad happens all
of a sudden you're like uh oh now i have
nobody to trade them to so i wonder if
they worry about that at all that any
more bad news gets out there to affect
this
i look you never know who else may come
forward and the window is open until the
relevant statute of limitations expires
whenever that may be usually it's at
least a year in personal injury type
cases it's two years from the date of
the incident i tend to think that we
already
you guys already got it all who's gonna
who's gonna
come out and and say something take
up the position where there's some
liability file a lawsuit whatever the
case may be it's been two months now
even though there's no binding
requirement that everyone speak now or
forever hold their peace within those
first two months i just think as a
practical matter we know what's out
there but but it's a good point look
sometimes you gotta strike while they
aren't hot you never know what kind of
curveball's gonna come your way to screw
everything up and uh they already
they've already been plunked in the head
by a curveball on this one uh and uh and
uh you know now they're just trying to
figure out the right time to make their
next move and if they do play it the
right way
there's still a chance if these cases
get resolved
you get a significant offer because
you've got multiple teams that
will bid against each other
and drive up the price i mean you know
peter king has suggested washington is a
destination
yeah and well if philadelphia is in the
mix too
yup you got two teams in the same
division miami
suggesting remember we i said at one
point why don't you get miami and the
jets at the table and have two teams
from the same division
you're increasing your urgency to get
him because if you don't your rival is
now the jets obviously won't be at the
table because they have zach wilson but
if you could get washington and philly
both into this
i hear you you just sit back and wait
for the price to go up so there's still
a chance they're going to get a huge
return for deshaun watson if they can
get these cases settled yeah agreed
there and i think you could get miami
involved in that mix if they were
interested then i don't know why they
wouldn't be now and listen i'll throw
out another one that i just think
you know two teams that we like denver
of course i wouldn't be shocked to hear
them get back in the mix and just as
much as we've heard from david tepper
and cal carolina about how badly even
though they made the trade for sam
darnold i would not be shocked to see
them get involved in the desean watson's
too special so i wouldn't be shocked to
get to hear them get involved in that
conversation once again too
one thing that we have never heard about
the
the deshaun watson situation is where
he'd like to play we heard it from
russell wilson's agent mark rogers who
said russell wilson wants to stay with
the seahawks but if he were to be traded
he would accept the trade to the bears
the cowboys the saints or the raiders we
don't know where watson wants to go and
i think at this point that preference
probably is taking a back seat but it's
going to get back in the front seat if
we start getting these multiple teams at
the table you know i had i had pegged
the dolphins the eagles the panthers
washington
and the broncos those were i i set loose
odds a couple of weeks ago so we're
exactly on the same page yeah about the
teams that we think should be considered
i think so i think those are the teams
that jump out to me i think washington
like you've mentioned is the team that i
would
i would think is really interested i
mean they're building something there
and they got weapons there and things
where you i think desean watson would
look at it and be like hell yeah i'll go
play there right you know curtis samuel
and and terry mclaurin you know and and
now d'ami brown i mean they got
something going with that defense and
desean watson holy cow so yeah i think
those are the teams though i think those
are the obvious ones and the ones that
would be major players in that
conversation
and you never know who else may
may just decide hey this is my chance at
deshawn watson yes my quarterback
situation
is set for the current year but when am
i going to have a chance to get to sean
watson you know maybe a team that was
thinking
next year next year next year is when
will be available now all of a sudden
he's available this year if it gets to
that
maybe you see some teams rip up whatever
they were planning to do and try to make
a move for deshaun watson but but if
they can settle these cases i think this
is all going to uh
to go quickly
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports